le mode virtuel c'est le retour du grand
spectacle ce midi en présence du public
qui a commencé à arriver même si c'est
nuageux on craignait même un peu
d'averses alors on attend la gouverneure
générale et le premier ministre trudeau
et je retrouve mon collègue danielle
thibeault des coulisses du pouvoir
bonjour daniel à celui alors on se
rassemble on se retrouve c'est un retour
à la normalité puis je pense que ça fait
du bien beaucoup j'ai écouté au visage
que l'on voit sur les images qui nous
parviennent du séisme atteint
effectivement il ya beaucoup de plaisir
ya peut-être un peu de nostalgie ça fait
deux ans que la pandémie fait en sorte
que cette fête là elle se déroule de
façon virtuelle et c'est la première
fois aussi que l'on déplace les
festivités à l'extérieur de la colline
du parlement
c'est moi très loin mais quand même ça
devait se passer en fait la première
année de la pandémie première fois où on
annule y est fait et j'aurais dû avoir
lieu sur un site extérieur en raison des
travaux dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
il travaux sur l'édifice parlementaire
qui doivent durer une dizaine d'années
c'est déjà du jeu pris un peu de retard
alors donc c'est assez permanence ce
sera alors au moins pour un autre dix
ans et on a déplacé le grand spectacle
soirée va se dérouler un peu de ce côté
là un peu du côté du côté de
de gatineau aussi sur la place
dans le parc de la patte libye alors on
à fragmenter un peu les célébrations
s'est assuré qu'on pouvait quitter
centre-ville d'ottawa il ya toujours une
invitation qui est fait autour et si
vous voulez passer devant la tour de la
paix prendre une photo avec le parlement
mais dans les faits il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'activités qui se déroulent et
beaucoup de sécurité il faut le dire
parce que tout ça se déroule évidemment
avec un fond un peu de turbulences en
avant se souvient tous de ce qui s'est
passé et ce qui s'est passé en janvier
février les autorités policières de
ville d'ottawa autrement tirer des
leçons clairement parce que je peux vous
dire qu'au centre-ville on est pas mal
plus prudent du côté policier j'y étais
il ya 24 heures il y avait déjà des
barricades de monter il y avait déjà des
policiers qui s'assuraient qui avait pas
de gens qui stationnaient long des rues
qui avait pas de membre de manifestants
qui qui s'installait de façon de façon
permanente sur le site là bas vous allez
voir c'est très très clôturé sur l'essai
de la fête et il ya des contrôles de
sécurité supplémentaires qui se déroule
pour s'assurer que les manceaux un droit
de manifester les gens qui sont là ils
ont le droit d'aller manifester au
centre ville d'ottawa mais on veut
s'assurer que la fête n'est pas perturbé
pour les gens qui veulent retourner
célébrer le premier le 1er juillet la
fête du canada de façon normale c'est
comme y voilà et on espère que tout va
bien se passer alors beaucoup de gens
déjà beaucoup de rouge là sur le site
peut-être pas autant monde qu'on a déjà
vu par les activités où la météo est pas
aujourd'hui effectivement
on nous disait tout à l'heure quelques
gouttes de pluie qui ont été gardés
ressenti sur le ceva ces sites c'est
magnifique c'est très proche de
l'hystérie qui est utilisé pour des
spectacles en plein air durant durant
l'été on a combiné la fête du canada et
cette série de spectacles alors
justement pour nous parler de cette
ambiance qui règne sur les plaines le
breton je joins ma collègue valérie
gamache chaleur valérie c'est la
première fois on le disait depuis 60 ans
en fait depuis les tout débuts que les
festivités ne se déroule pas sur la
colline parlementaire
oui les spectateurs semblent quand même
avoir adopté ce nouveau site ce nouveau
au rendez vous les gens commencent donc
à se masser sont de plus en plus
nombreux au fur et à mesure que la
journée avance vous le disiez 1 ce matin
l'onu quelques gouttes depuis peut-être
que ça fasse en sorte que certaines
familles on a tendu la main à la toute
dernière minute avant de prendre la
décision de venir essayer de participer
aux célébrations de la fête du canada
jeudi quand on arrive ici aussi
peut-être que ce qui ralentit l'entrée
c'est qu'un important dispositif de
sécurité donc les sacs sont fouillés et
puis il faut passer à travers détecteur
de métal on veut vraiment s'assurer que
la fête se déroule en toute sécurité et
les familles sont la vitesse et des
familles qui sont effectivement heureuse
d'abord de se retrouver et de pouvoir
participer à ce genre d'activité donc de
retrouver la foule de retrouver ce
sentiment de célébrer ensemble de
chanter la tue 60 ans une famille que
nous avons rencontrée un peu plus tôt ce
matin c'est la première fois qu'on amène
les valeurs du canada donc c'est
important pour nous le puis surtout de
venir avant la pluie c'est cette journée
pour se livrer tout ce qu'on a accompli
tout ce qu'on est con famille ça vaut
vraiment la peine très important oui
pour qu'on parte et avaient tous les
maux canadien c'est très bon pour nous
ou alors des gens qui sont très heureux
d'être sur place on le sent et on
revient à des festivités qu'on
connaissait avant la pandémie un
petit voilà à quelques exceptions près
c'est à dire que c'est à dire que le
grand inspecteur va commencer cette
année par vraiment heureux cubain
autochtone donc on va déjà d'ailleurs et
voilà
je n'ai que quelques secondes donc je
veux faire de mon mieux pour dire ce que
j'ai à dire
les territoires son nom cd
qui veut dire que nous n'avons jamais
renoncer au droit que nous avons sur ces
territoires
le fait ne peuvent pas cité ses listes
restent importants de notre histoire
n'avons jamais perdu ces territoires
que ce soit à travers des combats ou
autrement
et il faut nous en souvenir
et que si aujourd'hui nous luttons pour
défendre ce territoire c'est à ce titre
souvient
alors c'est ce que nous sommes le peuple
anishinabe
c'est important de le rappeler
j'ai trop de mauvaise représentation
certaines personnes donc parfois se
représente
il est important de reconnaître que nous
sommes bien qu'ils nous sommes que nous
sommes ici pour représenter le peuple
algonquin anishinabe et notre territoire
et six ans que si vaste
cela correspond pratiquement au
territoire d'un pays comme la france
correspond à ce qu'est le territoire des
algonquins anishinabe ceci dit je veux
souhaiter la bienvenue à tous les
canadiens
bien sûr cette journée sera plus
difficile pour plusieurs d'entre nous
mais je vous souhaite la bienvenue sur
le territoire algonquin et china b
merci pour ces mots de bienvenue
à
notre grand chef le chef de la nation
algonquine
gouverneur général chez le ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres et à
toutes les canadiennes et les canadiens
nous sommes rassemblés ici aujourd'hui
pour réfléchir
manille 5 août c'est un bon les amours
célébrer l'une des nombreuses cérémonies
sacrées du peuple un et si nab et nous
allons bénir le lot
la première création no
nous invitons les canadiens à entrer
dans le cercle à prendre ce moment de
réflexion pour comprendre et pour
respecter
les normes contribution des peuples
autochtones notre sagesse nos
connaissances notre spiritualité
nous invitons les canadiens et les
autochtones ensemble à rentrer sur le
chemin de la bonté et de l'amour
ensemble nous allons reconnaître la
première création par cette cérémonie de
l'eau nous nous tenons en cercle
avec nos soeurs des premières nations
des métis des inuit nous avons beaucoup
à offrir
et ce que je dis aux canadiennes et aux
canadiens
rassemblons nous formons ce cercle de la
vie reconnaissant la beauté la beauté de
notre mère la terre
réfléchissons que nous sommes ici réunis
dans l'amour dans la boue et la bonté et
dans la paix
et avec tous les gardiens nous prions
quand vous accueillons dans notre cercle
nous sommes là pour écouter pour
réfléchir pour
respecter et pour
accueillir la sagesse autochtones
labonté autochtone l'amour autochtone
j'ai maintenant l'honneur d'inviter
à seraing et si nab et stéphanie
pelletier qui va animer présidé cette
cérémonie
de bénédiction de l'eau
chaude n'ai jamais vécu un week-end
contre monaco à
nintendo
qui n'a ni logo wii demande à langogne
mende à guiche gr guy mennereau going my
hand a sauvé mardi
mammosser gorgui sow mais n'a mis noir
mâle d'acné b me nouama bas jusqu'à
québécois meloche
ainsi nedjma
tiao des nems ou l inde allemand audi
kitsch est finie
be nice comment pis au king
of the world au monde à maiden et b de
maguy djigo et
anglais
cette cérémonie de l'eau que nous
célébrons aujourd'hui
c'est important pour nous nous
réunissons en tant qu une seule nation
mais
nous parlons aussi de l'eau l'eau est un
problème un enjeu non seulement pour les
autochtones mais pour l'ensemble de
notre planète
nous sommes ici pour reconnaître la
beauté de l'eau prier pour le pays où
que vous soyez quoi que vous fassiez
nous allons manquer
un sens pour honorer l'eau et invite
tout le monde à
s'unir à nous
en pensant à tout ce que l'on nous
apporte
le même que nous sommes tous et toutes
ici
je veux
souligner
la contribution de celles qui nous ont
précédés
je veux reconnaître la contribution de
l'anr feu ma mère
dont l'eau m'a porté à la ville nous
reconnaissons nos ancêtres se sait qui
nous ont précédés nous marchons sur
leurs traces
je vais donc offrir un champ
db
[Musique]
ok
gi joe
[Rires]
j'ai mes couettes j'aurais
m
les gens
du genre
[Musique]
hello
les b
et ce à deux
gillot
et me wade
ouais
m
lego
[Musique]
jawad
et
les beaux
bébés
il a deux
anigo
[Musique]
au
jarret
le
[Musique]
dg
[Applaudissements]
des nigauds
mais ouais j'aurais aimé d'or
desjardins
[Musique]
pour nous pourquoi nous sommes ici
nous sommes ici pour les enfants
et dans ce cercle ici il y a des enfants
nous allons
réunir nos esprits nos coeurs
nous
remercions notre mère la terre et l'eau
témoigne on nous cette bonté cet amour
les uns aux autres ce que nous célébrons
ici aujourd'hui c'est la vie nous
célébrons l'amour que nous recevons les
uns des autres nous célébrons ensemble
en frères et en seraient rappelons nous
que nous sommes là pour les enfants pour
mes enfants disons ensemble
alors voilà c'était cette cérémonie de
réflexion autochtone c'est un ajout aux
festivités plus traditionnels disons
cette année et c'était une cérémonie
de l'eau c'est à dire que les pays
peuvent des premières nations crois que
l'ol est vivante elle a un esprit elle
est sacrée un peu comme le sang de la
terre mère alors cette cérémonie ce une
façon de reconnaître et d'honorer cette
croyance et les femmes autochtones
partage un lien qui particulièrement
sacré avec l'esprit de l'eau à travers
leur rôle de porteuses d'enfants alors
daniel ça c'est un ajout qu'on a fait on
se souvient que l'année dernière ça lui
beaucoup d'autochtones avait même refusé
de participer ou de célébrer la fin il y
avait un énorme mouvement l'année
dernière pour annuler la fête du canada
et plusieurs plusieurs municipalités
avaient avaient emboîté le pas rappelez
vous on était dans les semaines qui
suivaient la découverte de sépulture
anonyme sur les terrains d'anciens
pensionnats pour autochtones ça va
commencer dans la région de kamloops sur
la côte ouest on en avait retrouvé
ensuite en saskatchewan et ça va créer
un mouvement et où les peuples
autochtones avait dit bon on peut pas
célébrer ce pays l'on peut pas le
célébrer dans de cette façon là dans le
contexte actuel on avait mis les
drapeaux canadiens en berne rappelez
vous l'année dernière le 1er juillet les
drapeaux canadiens étaient en berne sur
tous les édifices fédéraux l'un ou de
l'autre du pays et cette annulation ce
mouvement annulons la fin du canada
avaient été respectées par plusieurs
plusieurs villes de grande ville
vancouver sont ferrand uni peg avait
décidé de mettre un terme à leurs
célébrations alors cette année et ça
fait partie de la réflexion qui est
entamée l'année dernière par le
gouvernement par les peuples autochtones
comment on peut inclure ces notions là
ces nouvelles notions comment on peut
poursuivre la réconciliation dans ce
genre d'événement ce que vous avez vu
aujourd'hui c'est la csc la célébration
de l'eau il y en aura d'autres ce camp
nou ce que l'on nous dit en coulisses
c'est que il va y avoir et ça va devenir
un thème un élément récurrent des
célébrations du 1er juillet il y aura
toujours un élément plus autochtone pour
rappeler ce lien pour leur faire
davantage de place pour faire plus de
place quoi parce que on veut rectifier
un peu le tir il inclure évidemment
serre est un sujet qui reste très
sensible parce qu'elle beaucoup
d'autochtones qui trouve que c'est une
bonne chose d'autre qui sont encore
assez réticent à célébrer cette fête du
canada est encore des ya encore des
peuples et accord des premières nations
autochtones qui sont plus ou moins
d'accord avec l'idée de se joindre à
pareille célébration je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya peu de il ya peu de
villes qui ont suivi le mouvement par
contre alors on voit la garde d'honneur
qui se prépare parce que vous avez
aperçu tout à l'heure la gouverneure
générale mairie saimone le premier
ministre trudeau son épouse ses enfants
tous ces gens vont se déplacer
maintenant vers la scène principale où
aura lieu le spectacle donc il devrait
commencer vers 12h15 et donc on attend
la gouverneure générale qui va recevoir
le salut vis royal et ensuite qui va
passer en revue cette garde d'honneur
qui est sur place
alors on a interrompu assez abruptement
notre collègue valérie la marge tout à
l'heure parce que la cérémonie est
arrivé donc on essaiera de la retrouver
un petit peu plus tard et ont sans
exclusion l'histoire l'a retrouvé un peu
plus tard tout à l'heure donc évidemment
mairie simons et sa première célébration
de la fête du canada quand gouverneure
générale 1 première femme autochtone
occuper ce poste
et ça reste toujours un peu controversé
mais on l'a vu tout à l'heure dans cette
cérémonie de l'eau qui était célébrée
donc tout à côté un peu en arrière de
cette scène en fait ouais voilà alors
vous est ce cette semaine et se trouve
sur pour les gens qui sont familiers
avec la géographie de la capitale
nationale elle se trouve juste en face
du musée canadien de la guerre qui est
bâti qui est situé le long de la rivière
des outaouais alors essentiellement ils
ont traversé le petit sentier derrière
pour aller tenir la cérémonie de l'eau
juste à côté du musée de la guerre tout
près de la rivière des outaouais mairie
ça emon vous disiez controversé toujours
cette nomination la auprès de plusieurs
communautés autochtones ya des gens qui
disent comment on peut comment on peut
avoir été la reine voir nommé l'une des
nôtres comme représentant de la couronne
au canada représentant de l'ars alors
que l'on ne reconnaît pas s'être 1 alors
que c est évidemment il y en a d'autres
qui vont vous dire peut-être qu'il faut
être à l'intérieur du système pour le
faire changer on le voit dans d'autres
cultures en nouvelle-zélande par exemple
on a fait beaucoup beaucoup de place aux
indiens maori et et on a on a énormément
de dans ses célébrations là il ya
énormément de connotations autochtones
qui sont qui sont rappelés et
dans ce contexte là la présence de
madame ça émeut dans une attaque que ça
peut faire changer les gens très bien là
on va pouvoir retourner justement voir
notre amie valérie valérie vous êtes là
pour nous parler un peu de l'ambiance
oui alors on reprend où on avait laissé
donc on revient à ce effet révélé qu'ils
sont cons connaissait en fait avant la
pandémie y avait cette différence cette
cérémonie autochtone au tout début et
maintenant on va revenir au spectacle
hu est absolument dans le discours du
premier ministre des sourds de la
gouverneure générale et si les gens sont
heureux d'être de retour ici sur place
de pouvoir donc elle participe et
célébrer ensemble mais aussi les
artistes sont très contentes on voit le
premier repas de la semaine de voir
aussi pouvoir aussi pouvoir donc je
voudrais retrouver
le public est là pour eux c'était
important de le faire et des artistes
qui sont ici qui ont aussi un message de
passion c'est que la communauté
ukrainienne est extrêmement importante
au canada alors ya cette chanteuse
manitoba chantal kreviazuk et qui va
chanter tantôt avec une pensée
particulière pour les gens de l'ukraine
parce que elle est donc de pair
l'ukrainien est pour elle c'est
important lors de ce spectacle de
rappeler que le canada donc et aux côtés
de l'ukraine dans cette guerre
actuellement qui se passe bien loin
évidemment est du si et puis il ya
l'artiste usa leblanc l'acadienne donc
qui va venir une tournure sauf une
chanson bien spéciale qui parle de son
village du nouveau brunswick vos
services jeu s'entendre les deux
artistes
on est ici et on ne va pas changer notre
position nos positions notre position et
c'est que on est ici pour vous et on ne
va pas partir pour moi c'est juste comme
un hommage à mon petit village qui sait
comme c'est tellement c'est hier qu'a
fait dans chaque petit village que ce
maire jean raffard le bcs est juste
devenue tellement naturellement j'ai
grandi avec ça c'est tout différent ce
que j'ai entendu de 80 millions
voilà vous l'entendez les artistes
croate aussi de remonter sur scène de
revenir à la rencontre de ce public et
de partager aussi ce message qui s'était
pourtant maintenant de se retrouver et
puis dans les prochaines minutes bien on
entend le premier ministre qui doit donc
venir ici pour assister à ce grand
spectacle oui le premier ministre
trudeau qu'on voit en train de serrer
des mains il est accompagné donc de son
épouse sophie grégoire trudeau et de ses
trois enfants xavier qui a 14 ans
maintenant et la grise 13 ans et adrien
huit ans ils sont accompagnés du
ministre du patrimoine canadien pablo
rodriguez et il ya aussi des leaders des
organisations nationales autochtones la
gouverneure générale elle se prépare
pendant ce temps pour aller recevoir
luceville le salut vis royal voilà alors
messieurs tout cas pas l'air trop
fatigué de son long voyage j'allais dire
parce que il ya plus de gens qui savent
mais il a il est revenu d'une tournée
d'une dizaine de jours en europe et en
afrique hier soir un peu après 23 heures
sortie une courte nuit quand même j'ai
trudeau qui participait au sommet de
haut sommet de l'otan au sommet du g7 et
qui avance avait participé au sommet du
commonwealth en parler de royautés tout
à l'heure alors il était là-bas avec les
homologues des autres pays du
commonwealth et le thème commun de tout
ça évidemment ça a été beaucoup
d'ukraine chantal kerbadj accord on
parlait tout à l'heure on a énormément
parlé de la situation en ukraine on a
fait beaucoup de pression entre autres
sur les autres pays du commonwealth
certaines sont plus réticents à dénoncer
l'invasion russe là bas on a toujours
continent a poursuivi la réflexion sur
ce qui pouvait être fait pour aider
davantage du crâne en matière de
sanctions économiques en maths et et
monsieur trudeau a conclu périple
justement non simple participation
cheveux militaires supplémentaires
l'ouverture d'ambassades dans les pays
baltes nouvelle présence au sein des des
forces d'intervention rapide de l'otan
aussi ses traits sont quand même un
certain changement le discours le
premier ministre a obtenu
rappelé le soutien du canada l'appui du
canada à l'ukraine mais quand même on ne
parle parle plus de repousser
complètement les russes mais plutôt
d'essayer de contenir un peu leur avance
et on verra s'il y aura des négociations
qui vont s'entamer mais on sentait quand
même que une certaine fatigue qui
s'installe je vais voter internationale
y avait peu de leaders cette semaine qui
qui se sont avancés pour dire où pour
définir ce qui serait une victoire
dorénavant beaucoup de et beaucoup de
discours sur le thème de l'ukraine doit
l'emporter mais qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une victoire ukrainienne ça on n'en
parlait pas mal moins cette semaine je
rends les différents sommets auxquels ce
conflit qui s'installe dans la durée on
entre dans le cinquième mois de combats
donc c'est peut être plus long que ce
que l'on croyait alors monsieur trudeau
dont qui va accorder des deux courtes
entrevues à nos collègues de siby ci
ainsi que radio canada donc on va
l'entendre dans quelques minutes pendant
qu'on voit cette garde d'honneur qui
attend la gouverneure générale un peu
particulier aussi parce qu'on les a vus
il était déjà sur le site ce matin
normalement sur la colline du parlement
dans la fête dans la fête nationale sous
sa forme originale ils vont arriver il
arrive de 20 il arrive devant la flamme
du centenaire ils descendent le petit
bain de foule que monsieur trudeau afin
évidemment c'est en revenant de la
cérémonie du lot derrière en passant
près de la foule
c'est devenu s devient un exercice que
tout le hockey tous les produits ne
seraient peut-être d'autres peut-être un
peu plus que les autres mais à les voir
la foule allait rencontrer ces gens-là
qui souvent est ce matin je sais pas
quelle heure ils ont commencé à arriver
mais tu te sers yvetot pour avoir de
bonnes places devant la salle comme on
craignait les orages peut-être que les
gens attendent eu un petit peu et juste
pour expliquer le public n'était pas
admis à cette cérémonie dont qu'il veut
nos camarades nos caméras étaient là
donc on a pu voir l'événement mais en
fait on voulait que ça se fasse un peu
dans l'intimité un peu en privé avec des
gens qui comprennent qu'ils apprécient
qu'ils comprennent ce genre de cérémonie
c'était important mais comme on le
disait ces cérémonies qui vont devenir
maintenant qu'ils vont faire partie des
célébrations de la fête du canada le
thème le thème autochtone thème première
nation va définir votre définitivement
devenir un élément qui va être
renouvelée à tous les ans et j'en
discutais avec des gens dans l'entourage
de monsieur rodriguez pablo rodriguez
ministre du patrimoine hier est ce que
ce sera toujours la cérémonie de l'eau
peut être pas est-ce qu'on ira vers des
traditions autochtones d'autres nations
est ce qu'on se est-ce qu on se dirigera
dans dans d'autres rites c'est tout à
fait possible mais y est clair en tout
cas la réflexion chez les gens qui
organisent la fête du canada c'est qu'
il faut faire davantage il faut
s'assurer que les premières nations
canadiennes ont davantage de place et je
pense qu'au fur et mesure où la
cérémonie d'aujourd'hui va pas se
dérouler vous allez voir qu'on leur a
réservé deux petits moments ici et là
encore c'est comme ça un peu partout à
travers le pays dans les dents les plus
petite cérémonie qui se déroule ailleurs
dans les provinces dans les villes les
villages ça fait ça fait beaucoup ça
fait beaucoup partie des thèmes qui ont
été mis à l'avant à l'avant plan du
programme politique de monsieur trudeau
quand il est arrivé en 2015 rappelez
vous on parlait on rappelait on parlait
de réconciliation on parlait de rétablir
les liens entre le gouvernement canadien
et les premières nations autochtones peu
partout à travers le pays monsieur
trudeau
ae et v6 d'énormes d'énormes sommes
d'argent là dedans on voit justement
aller l'écouter parce qu'il est avec
notre collègue agréable de pouvoir se
rassembler tous en personne encore une
fois j'ai envie de vous dire bon retour
à la maison après ce congrès se sont
toutes ses missions le g7 le teint quand
vous êtes rentré hier soir c'est quoi le
sentiment quand on rentre à la maison et
on sentait tout ça faisait dix jours on
a fait des choses très important parce
qu'on est en train de faire face à des
enjeux globaux qui ont un impact chez
nous mais m'ont dit que ça fait du bien
de pouvoir venir ici avec les foules
aujourd'hui de reconnecter avec tout ce
qui nous rassemble en tant que
canadienne la cérémonie la les
festivités ont débuté par cette
cérémonie autochtones où tout le monde
s'est tenue la mer vous êtes arrivé ici
aussi en serrant des mains une scène
qu'on aurait pu imaginer il ya encore
quelques mois c'est un soulagement pour
vous et vous le sentez pour les gens qui
sont ici de pouvoir enfin se réunit oui
absolument là c'est vraiment l'esprit de
pouvoir se revoir de pouvoir serrer des
mains de pouvoir sa cote et les gens
contre les autres une belle journée
comme ça on a passé des moments
extrêmement difficiles pendant deux ans
pis il y en a encore des tissus l'avenir
mais prendre un moment pour vraiment se
dire non non on est on est canadien on
est là les uns pour les autres c'est ce
qu'on célèbre aujourd'hui ça fait du
bien de ne plus donner de consignes aux
canadiens mais dans fait de leur dire de
ces libres oui ça fait vraiment du bien
pouvoir dire écoutez oui il va falloir
qu'on fasse attention particulièrement
un rendu à l'automne l'hiver mais pour
aujourd'hui la con s'élèvent tout ce
qu'on a pu faire et surtout tout ce
qu'on va continuer de faire ensemble
c'est tout doux il ya quand même des
gens qui sont là pour manifester à des
gens qui ont été peut-être porter dans
leur valeur pendant cette pandémie par
certaines de vos décisions est ce que le
défi postpandémique justement pour le
canada c'est pop c'est de rétablir cette
unité canadienne est ce que ça c'est
important pour vous il est comment voyez
arriver d'abord depuis plusieurs années
on voit que la fête du canada pour
certains peuples autochtones ça leur
tente pas de célébrer on trouve la place
pour pour accepter ça pour pour
apprendre d'eux et pour travailler
ensemble je pense que c'est la même
chose pour ceux qui se sentent
un petit peu frustré par rapport à ce
qu'on a dû faire en tant que pays
pendant les dernières années on va
rester ouvert qu'on passionné pour pour
accompagner les gens mais quand même à
pour se garder en sécurité parce que oui
la coved et pas partie on va la mettre
de côté aujourd'hui mais à la proche de
l'automne et de l'hiver il faut qu'on
continue d'être d'être là et d'être bien
pour les uns que les autres je souhaite
une bonne fête du canada ça va se passer
en famille pour le reste de la journée
me reste la journée en famille entre
amis à jouer dehors que est célébré
comme tellement de familles à travers le
pays je félicite pour les petits détails
la cravate les bois aussi les bas à
l'issue du canada vraiment faut porter
sa fierté aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
baissé premier ministre bercy
alors justin trudeau merci valérie
justin trudeau donc qui porte fièrement
le drapeau canadien sa cravate et ses
basses l'habitude séduire et basse et sa
mère donc monsieur trudeau on le disait
qu'y qu'ils étaient contents de revenir
au pays après cette tournée et ça a été
un début d'année difficile 10 pour tout
le monde ça a été difficile mais pour le
gouvernement tout ça a été difficile
l'occupation centre-ville d'ottawa ça a
été compliqué ça a fait en sorte que le
gouvernement a dû monsieur trudeau a dû
devenir celui qui me disait la loi est
bonne c'est la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence pour une première fois et ça
ça
ça choque et tamas a permis de libérer
centre-ville du gouvernement mais en
même temps
l'utilisation cette lola est sous la
loupe maintenant devant un comité et il
ya de sérieuses questions qu'ils se
posent sur était ce nécessaire et donc
c'est encore compliqué ça pour monsieur
trudeau et manifestations toute la
question des mesures sanitaires on a
beaucoup reproché aux personnes qui se
déplacent vers la gare de donneurs on a
beaucoup reproché au gouvernement de
traîner les pieds un peu là dessus il y
avait plusieurs juridictions à travers
le monde qui avait laissé tomber bien
des mesures sanitaires et au canada on
disait que la science faisait en sorte
qu'on avait toujours que c'était
toujours important de maintenir
l'utilisation du passeport vaccine à
l'utilisation des masques dans les
endroits publics etc etc là aussi il a
été critiqué là dessus là où ça peut
être été un peu mieux pour monsieur
trudeau c'est la gestion de la crise du
crédit yen ou la nuit
la ministre des affaires étrangères le
ministre de la défense la vice-première
ministre madame flüelen qui est que des
as qui a des racines ukrainien
évidemment ces quatre individus les
membres du gouvernement ont relativement
bien géré le dossier quand on en parle à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur du pays
s'est vu de façon plutôt favorables au
canada quand même accueilli 52 mille
craignant la plupart sont venus avec les
parrainages privé ans à ses membres en
france voilà par leurs propres moyens
certains sont arrivés sur des avions
nolisés si c'est ça aussi ça a été le
sas a fait l'objet de critiques de la
part du gouvernement pourquoi n'at-on
pas pu ne lisez plus que trois avions
parce que ce qui est c'est ce qui a été
réservé par le gouvernement fédéral pour
amener des déplacés craignant ici
monsieur trudeau a eu de la difficulté à
organiser toute l'opération fort
ministre de l'immigration aussi la
saisie bon retour à la normal j'avais
entendu dans discours retour à la
normale mais pour l'instant pour
l'instant parce que il ya encore cette
menace d'une nouvelle vague pour
l'automne oui ensuite repartis à la
hausse le nombre de cas et c'était et
c'est aussi la réponse qu'il a servie
est directement aux manifestants qui
sont à quelques à moins de deux
kilomètres de là au centre ville qu'est
ce que vous leur dites à ces gens là je
les comprends je veux faire preuve
d'empathie à leur égard mais attention à
la sécurité il faut faire attention
notre sécurité
il monsieur trudeau qui était
visiblement très heureux d'être avec des
gens dans une foule il il fonctionne ça
lui sied bien une folle monsieur trudeau
is aliments de l'énergie des gens qui
sont autour de lui sont petites
confidences qu'il m'a fait dans le passé
il aime beaucoup cette connexion là et
quand on le voit se déplacer dans une
foule comme ça ça paraît alors on va
écouter la gouverneure générale qui a
pris place donc sur l'estrade pour le
salut vis royal
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous allons donc qui passe en revue la
garde d'honneur et qui cassent et
attentionnée elle s'arrête elle elle
parle avec chacun d'entre eux c'est là
donc c'est donc la 30e gouverneur
général du canada elle a été assermenté
en juillet 2021 de saisie donc sa
première fête du canada autant
gouverneur général et c'est la cinquième
femme et bien sûr la première
représentante autochtone à occuper ce
poste
madame simone donc qui continuent d'être
sujet de critique et de controverse
parce que elle est bilingue évidemment
mais anglais inouk alors que une petite
hook alors que certains lui reprochent
de ne pas parler le français même si
elle prend des cours mais de ne pas
suffisamment parler le français et on
n'a pas eu l'occasion de voir dans quel
état à quelle vitesse elle apprenait le
français encore vallée
les quelques mots qu'elle prononce en
français sont toujours scripté et fait
très attention ce serait intéressant
voir à quelle rapidité et pour un
maîtriser être en mesure de discuter
peut-être plus directement avec les gens
mais ça fait encore ça fait encore en
sorte que le gouvernement fait l'objet
de critiques sur une base pratiquement
quotidiennes le chef du bloc québécois
en parle régulièrement la période de
questions et mais c'est important pour
le gouvernement trudeau et c'était
c'était un désir du premier ministre de
tendre la main à un ou une représentants
des peuples des peuples autochtones des
premières nations pour pour le poste de
gouverneur général on disait que lors de
la première nomination
monsieur trudeau avait en fait le comité
et les gens responsables de d'aller à la
recherche de candidatures potentielles
avaient eu de la difficulté justement à
trouver un candidat des premières
nations une cantate des premières
nations qui était en mesure
et est clairement la deuxième ronde la
deuxième après le départ de madame payet
monsieur trudeau et son entourage ont
juste dire bah tant pis on va y aller
pour quelqu'un qui est bilingue mais qui
parle pas nécessairement français puis
on s'engagera à ce qu'ils l'apprennent
ya un autre défi qui s'en vient pour
monsieur trudeau bientôt sur la
nomination d'un juge à la cour suprême
et là aussi ce que l'on entend beaucoup
c'est qui une volonté que ce soit un
membre des premières nations qui
s'installe qui s'installe avec tous les
autres membres du plus haut tribunal du
pays
alors en principe après cette revue de
la garde d'honneur là qui dirigeait
d'ailleurs par le major tremblay
on s'attendait à voir les snowbirds mais
les snowbirds
n'y seront pas officiellement parce que
y'a un problème technique là qu'il
touche le dispositif de réglage qui
permet l'ouverture des parachutes donc
ça cloue les avions au sol évidemment
c'est un problème le problème majeur oui
c'est un problème majeur il vaut mieux
les garder au sol mais les gens vont
opérer un peu déçu parce que ça fait
toujours partie de ces cérémonies c'est
un moment toujours très appréciée c'est
la formation dès la formation du
snowboard qui qui qui monte à la
verticale derrière la tour de la paix en
faisant en forme de
feuille d'érable et c'est toujours c'est
toujours fantastique de les voir si bien
chorégraphiés ses avions ses les avions
de l'argent il faut le dire la flotte de
snowbird les vieux tuteur ils sont là
depuis un petit bout de temps alors les
problèmes mécaniques
c'est pas inhabituel ou c'est pas
surprenant et ils ont eu un accident à
l'année dernière durant spectacle aérien
qui a coûté la vie à l'une des pilotes
d'ailleurs et dans ce contexte là on ne
prend clairement pas de chance voilà
notre s'allient pour la vis pour la
gouverneure générale
[Musique]
alors voilà c'est la fin de cette partie
plus protocolaire un peu de ces
festivités ce midi le spectacle va
commencer dans quelques instants et avec
des beaucoup beaucoup d'artistes dont
lisa leblanc sarah may et plusieurs
autres et
d'un gouverneur général se déplace
maintenant vers la scène principale où
elle va être installée avec les autres
dignitaires pour regarder ce spectacle
est accompagnée de son mari witt fraser
qui est avec elle et voilà qui salue les
gens qui sont installés pour déjà pour
voir ce spectacle beaucoup de gens sur
les plaines le breton je vous rappelle
que c'est là que se déroule ces
festivités aujourd'hui puisqu'il y a de
gros travaux sur la colline
parlementaire ça va encore durer
quelques années donc c'est là que vont
se dérouler dorénavant les festivités en
tous cas au cours des prochaines années
céline je remarque une présence
policière qui me semble plus importante
que par les années passées il ya
toujours des gens d'habitude il ya des
des policiers en civil la grc qui sont
là pour assurer la sécurité de la foule
mais il me semble y avoir davantage de
policiers autour des près des barricades
qui qui protège la section qui réservait
justement oui parce que beaucoup de
sécurité avec les manifestations on a
commencé à voir de la manifestation hier
les jeux des arrestations on a donné
beaucoup de contraventions et on a
appris les leçons de ce qui s'est passé
il ya quelques mois quand même à ottawa
où on aime donc on a mis une présence
policière beaucoup plus fort et je pense
qu'on ne tolérera pas d'écart donc c'est
sur le point de commencer à regarder ça
tous ensemble en vous revient après ce
grand spectacle
david laflèche et maintenant pour nous
interpréter l'hymne national du canada
accueillez l'artiste natif de
charlottetown à l'île-du-prince-édouard
car mme klein avec la collaboration de
l'autre compositeur interprète david
laflèche
[Musique]
1 me rendais
année
je
là
et
non
carton blanc s'est
entêté
il sert orthez lacroix
[Musique]
ton histoire
es tu et beaucoup
mais plus
une
bla
ma mère
coc
ce fruit
[Musique]
comme pour
oh
je
là qui sait
non
à
lee
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour m
c'est nous
tu donnes
c
[Musique]
g
charest
[Musique]
apithy
nous
[Musique]
engageant sur les sentiers rabattu du
passé s'engageant dans les sentiers
débat dessus de l'avenue la jeunesse
engager entend s'élever dans
l'écroulement de l'édifice
progresser sur un chemin devrait changer
le monde depuis sa logique recoudre un
filet social à coup de coude qui seul
pour une terre d'accueil entre trois
océans pour que la feuille d'érable
verdissent avenant que l'avenir le
soient les générations présentes avance
au son de leurs bois et dans la croisée
des chemins de croix
force de marcher droit comment alors
quoi
si vous voulez
[Musique]
il
bah
de
grosses
[Musique]
sommes
inspiration to peer
il y a
mais
[Musique]
c'est humain
doué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
rien
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour tout le monde est bienvenu à la
cérémonie du midi de la fête canada dans
la capitale c'est tellement fun de vous
revoir ici en personne je m'appelle à
narnia bienvenus
comment allons-nous canada fait du bruit
bonne fête grâce à bienvenue à l'agonie
du midi de la fête du canada dans la
capitale nationale
nous avons eu une très belle exécution
de la chanson de johnny macho merci aux
artistes
la clinique sans cette chanson a
peut-être 45 ans mais les à johnny 30 et
la semence de l'importance de protéger
l'environnement comme les enfants que
nous venons de voir ont bloqué des
arbres tout spécial à l'ucp tiers il lit
ou coupal pour leurs témoignages ainsi
qu aux danseurs choristes et musiciens
c'est vraiment magnifique qu'ensemble
vous redonner vie à la chanson bégayant
l'ottiaq 6 2 jo ni mondiaux parce que
malgré ses 45 ans elle reste encore
beaucoup d'actualité lorsqu'elle a écrit
johnny mettions les thèmes visionnaire
elle semer une graine dans notre esprit
la même manière que les enfants que vous
voyez ici que vous avez vues dans ce
numéro leur sèmeront physiquement des
arbres à leur tour un très beau geste
pour l'environnement
cette année au lieu d'être sur la
colline du parlement nous sommes à
quelques coins de rue
je m'en réjouis parce qu'après deux ans
de pandémie je me sens beaucoup mieux
ici que sur la colline vous n'êtes pas
forcé donc il faut sourire habituel
c'est tellement agréable que les
célébrations de la fête du canada soit
de retour devant une foule à l'extérieur
merci voilà la wii
vous nous avez manqué et c'est
formidable ligne ainsi de ce public est
électrisante et nous avons une fête
extraordinaire pour vous aujourd'hui ce
premier numéro a donné le ton à la
célébration cette année qui a un thème
très à propos des années qu'on vient de
vivre les chemins et tous les artistes
aujourd'hui on ce point en commun un
patrouilleur en fait nous avons tous et
toutes quelque chose en commun les
dernières années nous ont conduits sur
des voies différentes les voies de la
diversité de l'accusation en ivoire de
la guérison mais aussi la reconnaissance
des changements climatiques et leur
impact sur notre environnement
mais tous ces chemins nous sommes ici
aujourd'hui
ils ont permis d'avancer ensemble ces
chemins nous on venait mener vers la
réconciliation par une conscience de
l'environnement et comme vous l'avez vu
mais on peut se fier sur les jeunes pour
nous guider à travers tout ça
et surtout aujourd'hui
nous venons ici à ottawa pour célébrer
notre grand pays
à l'autre mais en restant en plein coeur
du canada dans la capitale ici à
[Musique]
et pour lancer le bal voici quelques
monte sur le prochain invité à fouler la
foule il ya la charge de soutenir les
travailleurs dans les secteurs culturels
et artistiques de travailler avec les
premières nations pour assurer la
transmission leur culture entre autres
notre premier invité responsable de
protéger la musique le film et
l'industrie du cinéma quelqu'un qui
connaît très bien l'importance des
artistes pour promouvoir l'esprit du
canada de ministre du patrimoine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut à toi gueye canada warda
c'était des numéros extraordinaires
talentueux passionnés c'est notre avenir
c'est notre tour day of you tube ils
sont notre avenir cet incroyable de
merci merci à vous tous et vous toutes
et regardez vous
regardez vous
vous êtes beau
vous êtes vraiment beau
c'est formidable d'être ici pour la
première fois depuis 2000 19 en personne
ce que vous sentez l'énergie je veux
vous entendre
elle est où
après plus de deux ans de distanciation
c'est formidable d'être ensemble de
nouveau et je vous regarde je vous
regarde tous et toutes et je suis fier
je suis si fier de vous voir si nombreux
qu'ils brandissaient le drapeau canadian
d'unifoliés notre drapeau
regardez regardez les gens autour de
vous je vois déjà tous les genres les
visages du parrot origine je vois des
canadiens partout à ce qu'il y ait avoué
je vois une telle diversité de personnes
qui se sont réunies pour célébrer ce que
ça veut dire que d'être canadien pour
célébrer ce beau pays et les autochtones
aussi qu'ils ont toujours pris soin de
ce pays célébrer nos différences les
choses qui font notre force de célébrer
les grands artistes canadiens qui nous
font comme unité entre nous pour
célébrer les athlètes qui font notre
fierté nos champions olympiques et
paralympiques pour célébrer notre
culture des valeurs qui nous sont
communes et pour nous célébrer les uns
les autres n'est ce pas pour nous fait
et nous célébrer
rosso mais aussi pour réfléchir
réfléchir aux leçons de notre histoire
et pour nous engager à faire mieux à
devenir meilleur alors que nous y voyons
ensemble vers la réconciliation
que signifie le canada pour chacun
d'entre nous parce que chacun d'entre
nous a sa propre histoire son propre
chemin et ce sont tous ces chemins
chacun de ces choix là qui nous amène à
célébrer ensemble ce que c'est d'être
canadien moi j'arrivais ici comme
réfugié politique avec ma famille on
arrivait au canada plein pays
d'opportunités comme disait mon père un
pays ou une démocratie forte pour un
jeune argentin qui parlait ni un mode
française ni un mot d'anglais peut se
tenir devant vous aujourd'hui et vous
dire à quel point je suis fier d'être
canadien un pays avec des valeurs phare
des valeurs de solidarité d'équité de
responsabilité de compassion
aidera besoin et c'est ça la fête du
canada c'est à propos de vous il s'agit
de vous de chacune et de chacun de vous
qui
donnez vie à nos valeurs vous qui en
étant fidèle à ce que vous êtes fait
briller notre pays comment vous inspirer
vos proches vos amis les collectivités
où vous vivez
vous qui vous présenter pour
ceux qui ont besoin de vous pour que
ensemble de nous puissions bâtir un
avenir plus radieux et
savez il n'ya pas deux catégories de
canadiennes et canadiens est un canadien
et un canadien
[Applaudissements]
à toutes ces choses qui me rend fier y'a
vraiment fier d'être canadien et puis
aujourd'hui pour célébrer avec des
performances d'artistes vous n'avez vu
des gens vont en avoir plein ce midi ce
soir et ça va être une journée
magnifique et j'espère quelques mois
vous allez profiter de chaque moment
parce que je pense gagne
[Musique]
oui deux heures tout seul oui nous
méritons de nos chers et break
célébrons le canada bonne fête du canada
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
formidable merci ministre rodriguez
et félicitations à double dip
et
stimule notre énergie vous avez
tellement de culture riche diversifié au
sein de nos frontières et l'importante
de découvrir et de célébrer chaque une
deux
avec autant de communautés culturelles à
l'intérieur de nos frontières et quand
on pense à l'évolution d'une culture
malchance fait du tort que ça passe
beaucoup par la langue mais vingt noms
d'oiseaux ont fait ce poison je le
prends en octobre notre prochaine
invitée à d'ailleurs bien compris
l'importance de jouer avec la langue
depuis dix ans elle s'amuse à mélanger
le français l'anglais le chien pour nous
faire part des crs un accent notre
prochain artiste est un exemple
extraordinaire de la diversité n'est
dans les maritimes est ce qu a dit marie
six missiles
alors c'est acadienne célèbre but en dix
ans de carrière
provenant directement de son village
rodez reviennent au nouveau brunswick
avec justement un mélange de rock mais
des conduits et même plus récemment
le wac grands tubes
disco nous fait découvrir le chant
maubeuge où était son dernier album
chaque disco va nous faire danser avec
sa joie de vivre et nous présence à ces
camps ce discours
lancer en mars dernier accueillez lisa
leblanc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
go
par pas ça
[Musique]
bhl
ces cochons
méchant
[Musique]
pas
monde
[Musique]
maintenant
vous
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regarde toi
à
[Musique]
savoir quand
[Applaudissements]
encore une fois lisa leblanc
incroyable
alors que nous
cheminons sur la voie de la
réconciliation il faut pas oublier le
passé c'est important de regarder aussi
au delà de nos frontières car bien des
gens à travers le monde n'ont pas les
libertés que nous tenons pour acquise
mais en gardant le chemin parcouru pour
en arriver à la réconciliation
on ne peut s'empêcher de constater ce
qui se passe ailleurs où la liberté
n'est parfois plus qu'une illusion
prochains artistes partagent ce
sentiment
d'espoir qu'ils aient parfois difficile
je peux vivre quand on pense aux
épreuves que vivent les autres que sa
réponse et l'amour
l'autre et compositrice interprète
chantal très bien tu as travaillé avec
plusieurs stars d'appareils
elle est également décoré de l'ordre du
canada
à aider les personnes déplacées depuis
des années par son travail avec des
grands stylistes caritatives comme
l'ascendant secret diène faye que la
situation actuelle en ukraine fait pour
elle que la situation est beaucoup plus
difficile elle a travaillé récemment
avec le congrès mondial ukrainien pour
rassembler des ressources pour l'ukraine
et a prêté sa voix à un projet afin de
recueillir des dons et des denrées pour
le peuple ukrainien c'est dès
aujourd'hui elle nous rappelle la
puissance de l'amour pour provoquer le
changement comme souvent le sentiment
que tout est perdu
et après de la chanson au working with
war comme
chantal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
fort
legault
semaine ici
[Musique]
là
ouais
quelle vitesse
new film j'ai
mieux le fond dedans
vous
aucun doute
[Musique]
nascar
inquiétant
[Musique]
pierre c
m
oui
hu en france
[Musique]
ceux ci
yogen
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
chantal biya
[Applaudissements]
alors bravo à chantal kreviazuk
nous permettra de replonger dans les
exploits olympiques de nos athlètes oui
nous sommes fiers de nos jours est bien
de mettre les pieds et qui ont
compétition au juge raté que deux pékin
puis aux jeux olympiques et
paralympiques d'été et d'hiver
détermination et d'un courage sans
bandes comme s'ils avaient peur de rien
à nos yeux même avant de performer c'est
déjà des champions pour leur rendre
hommage on a demandé à deux artistes que
vous avez vu un peu plus tôt
d'interpréter une chanson vraiment trop
extrême l'expression que nous ressentons
en voyant nom exact let compétitionner
c'est notre façon de leur rendre hommage
pour l'interpréter aujourd'hui elle sera
accompagnée julie dassylva once again
encore une fois je lis da silva et
calais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est mauvais ohrid où est ton est ce
que
après qui sait
[Musique]
gaussin
c'est
[Musique]
il
c'est du déjà vu
c'est un portrait jusque là marie vien
reculer pour mai
on
parler
je tiens
[Musique]
jusqu'en ça
c
[Musique]
et
ces cas
[Musique]
m
à
deneux
je viens
qui veut plus
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sait
[Musique]
à
joseph y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci tout spécial à nos athlètes
olympiques et paralympiques
les rennais s'est
fait sa première apparition donc encore
paralympique
[Applaudissements]
rick et médaille d'argent donc ok
paralympiques
btk
à beijing en 2022
[Applaudissements]
ils sont les de représenter fièrement le
canada dans les po son encontre distance
qui mme boutin médaille de bronze
4 3 mais da
encore une histoire worms et
garantissent une autre athlète olympique
avec
vous savez jours la fête du canada c'est
la tradition pour notre prix ministre de
s'adresser au pays mais depuis deux ans
il a dû faire cette façon virtuelle
alors nous sommes ravis aujourd'hui il
soit là en personne aujourd'hui
traditionnel discours à la nation en
direct de la scène de la fête du canada
à ottawa veuillez accueillir notre
premier ministre le très honorable
justin trudeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle rêve loin
bonjour tout le monde
je suis désir d'être en famille
cette année aux personnes
[Applaudissements]
expériences vécues et vous célébrer
ensemble le pays que nous aimons et que
nous partageons pas ce que fait du
canada c'est la fête des canadiens
[Applaudissements]
notre pays ne serait pas ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui sans les gens qui l'ont
construit et qui continuent de le
construire tous les jours des gens comme
triste du rocher un jeune métis qui fait
de la sensibilisation du plaidoyer pour
la prévention du suicide et qui aide les
autochtones à devenir autonomes à
travers la musique et l'art des gens
comme la docteur ayme liste au médecin
qui a aidé à créé la première faculté de
médecine pour les femmes à la fin du 19e
siècle à une époque où les facultés
universitaires ne permettait pas aux
femmes d' étudier la médecine le canada
ce sont des gens qui luttent constamment
pour quelque chose et non pas contre
[Applaudissements]
quand terry fox a couru pour aig a
trouvé un traitement pour le cancer il
se battait pour améliorer la vie des
autres quand jean castelain devenue la
première femme noire et lieu au
parlement il a inspiré toute une
génération de jeunes femmes marcher sur
ses traces
nos produits ne serait pas ce qu'il est
sans les gens qui en font partie des
gens comme l'astronaute david saint
jacques qui explore toujours plus haut
et plus loin des héros comme guy lafleur
qui nous ont montré qu'on pouvait pas
être des champions
artiste extraordinaire comme d'hab
wacraft et charlotte cardin et les
autres qui ont joué pour nous
aujourd'hui qui racontent aux histoires
dans toutes leurs nuances leur art nous
aide à mieux comprendre de mieux nous
comprendre les uns les autres à quoi
c'est aussi l'histoire de personnes qui
travaillent dur plus en coulisses mais
en première ligne des gens comme femme
gloria carlo christina et tant d'autres
infirmières que j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer pendant la pandémie ce sont
de vrais héros de vraies héroïnes
canadienne est aujourd'hui comme tous
les jours nous les fêtons
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui nous célébrons aussi
des personnes dont les noms ne sont pas
bien connus comme les dizaines de
milliers d'ukrainiens et d'ukrainiens
qui gênent cas de plusieurs générations
sont venues dans les prairies pour
cultiver la terre et mettre de la
nourriture sur la table de notre peuple
nous célébrons et femmes et les hommes
en uniforme
qui sont là pour nous quand il ya des
feux de forêt et des inondations au pays
on célèbre aussi ceux qui sont en
mission ailleurs dans le monde loin de
leurs familles je pense entre autres aux
centaines de personnes voyez dans le
cadre de notre mission de l'otan en
europe de l'est ils font tous des
sacrifices pour assurer la sécurité des
canadiens et protéger notre liberté
nos valeurs et notre démocratie
oui nous nous hissons sur les épaules de
toutes ces personnes qui ont construit
notre pays avant nous et nous
travaillons fort tous les jours pour
ceux et celles qui vont nous suivre tous
les progrès que nous avons accomplis ne
sont pas arrivés par accident et ça ne
continuera pas sans effort nous avons la
responsabilité de faire progresser notre
pays pour les générations à venir
donc je comprends qu'il y à aussi de
graves erreurs des lacunes dans notre
histoire la découverte de marque anonyme
nous a obligé tous et toutes à mieux
apprendre notre histoire je connais la
douleur que cela a causés à beaucoup de
personnes aujourd'hui nous prenons le
temps de renouveler notre engagement
pour toujours être là les uns pour les
autres
le canada n'a jamais été parfait et
n'est pas parfait aujourd'hui oui le
canada est l'un des meilleurs pays au
monde mais notre nos efforts pour
l'améliorer ne se termine pas
les canadiens sont de bonnes personnes
et on vous dit bien les uns pour les
autres que ce soit de défendre la
démocratie de protéger l'environnement
d'avancer sur le chemin de la
réconciliation
ou de veiller à ce que tout le monde
puisse réussir aucun défi ni trop grand
si on le relève en sont et c'est ça que
notre drapeau représente nos valeurs et
tous nos efforts pour rendre notre pays
encore meilleur
d aucuns défi n'est trop grand si nous
le relevons ensemble c'est la promesse
du canada et c'est ce que représente
notre drapeau ils représentent nos
réalisations et notre désir de nous
améliorer chaque fois que nous voyons
l'unifolié rappelons-nous les valeurs
qu'il représente la compassion d'espoir
la responsabilité la justice l'ouverture
et le travail acharné
rappelons nous que si nous sommes
tranquilles millions de personnes qui
vivent sur six fuseaux horaires
différents de nos océans à l'autre nous
n'avons qu'un seul pays à partager à
protéger et à aimer
l'om et rappelons-nous les milliers
d'histoires de témoignages comme celui
d'ali réfugiés de l'ouganda qui vient
d'arriver au canada en juin à toronto
ali a
revêtu une chemise arc-en-ciel est là
célébrer la fierté ouvertement pour la
première fois de sa vie
[Applaudissements]
pouvoir être ce que vous êtes
pouvoir aimer qui vous aimé pouvoir
poursuivre vos rêves vivre sans peur et
cela met la liberté que représente notre
drapeau
à lui et à tous ceux et celles qui sont
arrivés ici la semaine dernière où le
mois dernier ou de l'année dernière sont
arrivés
bien depuis des millénaires
tout le monde au canada
vous êtes ici chez vous et aujourd'hui
c'est votre fait bonne fête du canada
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci au premier ministre et maintenant
passons au prochain numéro country
et pour certaines personnes comme cité
partout neige brûle même en alberta
alors l'alberta vous êtes ici
et
personne
at his coin de pays le d'achille du
canada
la muse a été l'album du pays lors des
prix juno ce qui faisait son dixième
récompense
qui récompensent meilleur des musiques
country ici même au pays
son prochain album est sorti en avril et
fait déjà un malheur et elle a déjà fait
des tournées et elle va entreprendre une
tournée en europe à l'automne
de moins de 30 ans ce livre donne
beaucoup à la société à travers une
organisation à but non lucratif qu'elle
a créée sous le nom de big red ce bikini
rose on est jeune il n'avait que 15 ans
quand elle a fondé cet organisme pour
recueillir de l'argent pour un nouveau
refuge dans l'épreuve
5 millions de dollars et son organisme
continue de grandir en plus d'aider
d'autres oeuvres de charité ouais ça
mérite d'être applaudi people alors
accueilli
notre chanteuse
je n'ai oscars
[Musique]
là
parce que 6
[Musique]
ce
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
ce pas
je suis
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
whatever à moi ça change
en fait cette année le 70e anniversaire
d'un événement historique pour le canada
et pour le monde
il y a maintenant soixante dix ans que
la reine elizabeth ii est montée sur le
trône c'est cette année son jubilé le
platine la population du commun noël des
gens dans le monde entier célèbrent cet
événement
john ses liens durables avec le canada
fait qu'elle a
couvert on a pratiquement la moitié de
l'histoire de notre pays et elle a fait
22 visite officielle au canada plus que
dans tout autre pays du commonwealth et
j'ai d'abord venu au canada en 1951
avant même d'être couronné et lorsque
j'avais 25 ans depuis lors les canadiens
ont pu l'accueillir d'un océan à l'autre
en 1982 que fait la charte des droits et
libertés une partie intégrante la
constitution du canada
la reine a célébré avec lui de nombreux
moments marquants pays comme l'expo 67 à
montréal
100e anniversaire
la confédération
ses nombreuses villes au canada on ne
peut oublier sa visite en 2002
lorsqu'elle a mis la rondelle au jeu
dans une partie des canucks de vancouver
avec un autre grave wayne gretzky
l'ensemble des provinces et territoires
du canada
incluant de nombreuses visites au sein
des communautés autochtones ces visites
qui ont permis de constater la diversité
et la richesse de nos cultures et nos
traditions merci sa majesté soutient
plus de 36 oeuvres de charité canadienne
et soutiennent des initiatives qui
encouragent le bénévolat et
l'inclusivité
canada peuple canadien pour souligner et
célébrer non réalisation alors qu'elle
canada qui définit comme une nation unie
malgré ces différences diversifiée et
ouverte sur le monde
à sa dernière visite en 2010
admirez la croissance du canada tout en
restant fidèle à son histoire à ses
valeurs caractéristiques
à sa majesté la reine elizabeth ii
[Musique]
soyeux jubilé de platine tout le monde
on voulait dire un peu plus tôt là mais
c'est vraiment un plaisir de vous
retrouver après ces deux années qui ont
été particulièrement éprouvants de se
retrouver tous ici anatomique et c'est
ce qui fait que cette journée six
spéciales
c'est une célébration de notre
résilience face à la diversité de notre
persévérance à travers les orages de la
vie et notre détermination de demeurer
unis en dépit de nos différences
félicité aujourd'hui c'est notre
capacité à faire face à l'adversité
c'est vrai que les canadiens ont leur
jamais on persévère et pensez-y c'est
certain que le froid et les hivers
rigoureux nous ont permis de forger un
caractère de battant et pour parler de
persévérance qui de mieux que la
première gouverneure générale d'origine
autochtone qui a elle même vécu dans le
grand nord
nous avons maintenant l'immense plaisir
de vous présenter la première
gouverneure générale autochtones du pays
veuillez accueillir son excellence la
raison râble général du canada son
excellence la très honorable mairie 100
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
bon dieu alors ils ont été arrêtées une
majorité
api canada des
[Applaudissements]
lois ou non mais attends
n'est pas
tout je veux reconnaître que nous sommes
réunis aujourd'hui sur le territoire
n'ont cédé du peuple algonquin et si nab
et c'est merveilleux de voir tout le
monde ensemble de nouveaux jours de la
fête du canada après ces deux années où
il nous n'avons pu nous rassembler c'est
une belle journée à célébrer
tous ensemble émis en premier il est
j'aimerais remercier
la canadian cow tous les efforts interor
l'après-midi pandémie
5 ue canada
pour tous les efforts accomplis pendant
la pandémie en particulier par les
travailleuses et travailleurs de
première ligne qui ont fait toute la
différence
ils sont une des grandes raisons pour
lesquelles nous pouvons de nouveau nous
retrouver ensemble et je tiens à les
féliciter pour leur travail
[Applaudissements]
ravi
que nous puissions de nouveau voir les
parents les amis et exprimer notre amour
pour notre pays
il ya tellement de choses auxquelles
nous pouvant avoir raté tellement de
jalons à célébrer
anticipé et s appelait
des cieux cette année nous soulignons le
jubilé de platine de sa majesté la reine
sa majesté a gagné notre respect pendant
les sept dernières décennies par son
engagement son esprit de service sa
constance et sa présence rassure à
nous célébrons aussi le 50e anniversaire
des décorations pour actes de bravoure
au cours de la dernière année j'ai eu le
privilège
d'apprendre aux côtés des canadiens qui
ont agi avec désintéressement pour
sauver une vie très souvent la vie de
quelqu'un qu'il ne connaissait pas
six tomes des autres les histoires des
bravo
les histoires des bénévoles ans
les histoires de persévérance les
espoirs de notre pays
i'm in spain bayonne par toutes les
histoires que j'ai entendu pendant ma
première année
qu'est ce que le canada sinon une
collection de voix et d'expériences
diverses nos histoires nous définissent
comme pays nous devons nous rappeler que
l'esprit de fête cependant ne s'étend
pas à tout le monde cette journée peut
aussi être un rappel de ce que nous
avons perdu
oui nous avons connu des pertes
tragiques pendant la pandémie et aussi
parce huit autres désastres d'origine
climatique et j'ai rencontré les peuples
autochtones qui continue de faire preuve
de force et de résilience mais qui
continue de pleurer une culture des
langues et des vies perdues cette
douleur est renouvelée alors qu'il
découvre des emplacements de marque
anonyme près des pensionnats autochtones
nous devons tous nous engager ensemble
sur la voie de la réconciliation et de
la guérison mais cela commence par la
compréhension et le respect
même avez peut-être entendu parler de
irene natta au cours de la dernière
année c'est une expression en inoki tout
cas et c'est une valeur importante pour
les inuit cela signifie ne jamais
abandonner
ça commence s'engager constamment à agir
nous entrons dans la pose et d'errance
diront les fans d'amy
dans l'autre sens wallace dans la
communauté partout au canada
et dans la détermination et espoirs de
la jeunesse
de travail envers au canada à la hauteur
du nord
à swiss à l'abri canabate
pippo inzaghi state dans un esprit à
continuer de construire une société
inclusive une société où nous puissions
être ce que nous sommes sans subir de
jugement une société à laquelle tout le
monde trouve sa place et faire preuve de
bonté et de compassion aujourd'hui et
tous les jours
ayez espoir en l'avenir je suis fier
t'appeler une canada mon pays et je suis
fière de vous appeler tous mes voisins
mes compatriotes
apparemment
on vient sur les murs au canada mais les
manettes renommée la lonato sma avocat
matin à tort ou leurs opinions et nos
radical et on l'a fait tout mon soutien
at any my face à lille où est mon mari
weeds joie damois pour souhaiter tous
les canadiens une très belle fête du
canada
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelle personne inspirante elle a
vraiment marqué l'histoire et continue
de le faire tous les jours speak in a
bag parlons d'excellence ça a été une
extraordinaire début de notre fête du
canada 2022 n'est ce pas
quelle meilleure façon de couronner
cette célébration
un
numéro de clôture musicale
autochtone décrétée par les nations
unies je crois que c'est pertinent de
prendre un moment pour qu on réitère
l'importance de donner une voix forte à
l'histoire et à la culture autochtone
partout au pays lg cup alors que nous
dansons la première année de la décennie
des langues cet automne proclamée par
les nations juniors une autocélébration
2010 culmine avec une célébration de la
diversité et de la culture à travers les
arts et la musique
celle qui viennent de remporter le prix
de l'artiste bretonne deux rennais aux
juno
il présentait son année au dernier gala
des prix juno dj shop est un fier
représentant du clan mourad des six
nations de la rivière grand est
considéré comme le parrain du para one
step sur la scène qui sera accompagné
d'artistes issus d'autres communautés
culturelles dont le rapport canado
mexicain boogaerts qui va apporter sa
musique au rythme hip hop cumbia salsa
et reggaeton
pour ajouter une violence féminine
sahara mais la rappeuse et canadienne
aura les rythmes africains et de vous en
prendre aussi une voix de ce pays ou qui
ne font jamais donc lui en tous sens
inouï ketsana menée
alors chantez vous gâte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
laissez les yeux pers donné ses acquis
me rendre en colombie
père de mes c est une grande pendait
[Musique]
alors ne pas louper l'enfant
à lombez la bagasse noah c'est nouveau
ça
la deuxième place cette chasse à l'homme
le
jeu
l'autre à l'eau
[Musique]
quant à l'eau
en baisse
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au paraguay
[Musique]
m
point
ouais mon amie bella qui perd là qui
comptait zorro comme un serveur au
maquis en ma vie et ce pack us de faire
du salbert se maquille pas pour
personnellement je vois ton équipe son
équipe mc solaar ophélie on vit là bas
pour
tous
lundi
jacques adeler
dans le calice mensonger tél
comme les chameaux des batailles comme
m
[Musique]
et
mais
[Musique]
b
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un
coup et
[Musique]
pas sûr
il
voilà
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était extraordinaire
incroyable
vous nous avez carrément coupé le sommet
en même temps donner tellement d'énergie
merci merci merci merci pour ce
magnifique numéro il se dit que le début
ainsi tu pensais que ce serait hautement
petit oiseau chambre en prêtant tôt j'ai
adoré travailler avec toi au
rct tout à plus ou travailler avec vous
et canada
applaudissons tous les artistes que nous
avons vu trois salles aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
doucement pendant la fête du canada sur
l'interaction de gilbert fradette
et les festivités ne font que commencer
ça se poursuit n'oubliez pas de vous
joindre à nous à 20h ce soir pour le
spectacle du soir de la fête du canada
sur les banques d'ici radio canada télé
que la célébration se poursuit partout à
travers le pays amusez vous bien mais
n'oubliez pas d'être là à 20h ce soir la
célébration du soir à radio-canada bonne
fête du canada tout le monde
voilà c'est la fin de ce spectacle du
midi qu'on avait pas eu depuis deux ans
déjà et donc il de retour daniel
discours du premier ministre beaucoup
d'inclusion comme dans le spectacle
c'est vraiment là tellement très
beaucoup de retours un gros retour sur
évidemment cette nécessité de relancer
l'opération réconciliation c'est le
thème qui était central à tous les
discours monsieur rodriguez en a parlé
mais resigned on a parlé aussi un peu un
peu un petit retour sur l'ukraine
également mais beaucoup l'art qu'est ce
qu'on surveille cet été aux oreilles on
surveille un été de plus normal un
stampede barbecue rencontre de policiers
avec le grand public c'est certain que
vous allez en voir davantage que ce que
l'on a vu dans les deux dernières années
sélection qui passe par la crise des
voyageurs on espère que tout ça va se
résorber rapidement le souhaitent et
puis évidemment
on garde un oeil sur la sélection du
prochain ca france amateur
très bien alors on va retrouver notre
collègue valérie gamache qui assistaient
à cet fête donc en compagnie d'une
famille de montréal valérie
voilà une famille de mots rien pour qui
ces biais spécial ses traits du canada
et jean part donc avec les stars sofia
lilly et carla l'instance et c'est quand
même spécial parce que c'est la première
fois que vous assisté à cette scène là
en tant que citoyen canadien qu'elle
vienne oui c'est la première fois que
j'ai célébré la journée de canada et
depuis 2010 9 on est devenus canal y
évoquait on est vraiment
fier d'être le pays le petit et on
habite normalement au québec mais on est
canadien est ce que vous savez et aimez
particulièrement dans ce spectacle la
musique que l'ambiance est très
familiale ya beaucoup de monde c'est la
première fois qu'on se rend compte
encore avec les gens on alors l'a pas
fait depuis deux ans mais la polémique
était tous à la maison mais aujourd'hui
on revienne à la normalité c'est
vraiment incroyable d'être ici votre
chanson préférée lors de ce spectacle
les et blanc c'est notre chanteur
préféré chanteuse préférée ok ça va
t-elle je vous soupçonne d'être un
amateur de tim hortons nesta oui on
l'aimé on avait tout était pourtant
donné mais ça aussi c'était magique on
va là merci beaucoup bonnetain du canada
vous mais si vous faites tout le monde
alors voilà que tu as quand je faisais
référence à cette chanson d'exa le plan
gossip qui la chanson préférée d'un star
et de carla et qui ont découvert
inévitablement le thé martin en
s'installant ici au canada en 2009 et
qui sont devenus citoyens canadiens et
donc il ya de ça un peu plus de 200 très
bien alors on leur souhaite une bonne
fête du canada merci beaucoup valérie
d'avoir été avec nous pour cette
émission au revoir et puis quelques
premiers ministres provinciaux ont voulu
souligner cette fête du canada à leur
façon sur les réseaux sociaux en
commençant par françois legault qui
écrit je souhaite une bonne fête du
canada à toutes les canadiennes et à
tous les canadiens et vous le voyez ça
message qui était accompagné d'une carte
du canada tout en bleu on peut imaginer
ce qu'on veut qu'est ce que ça veut dire
et le premier ministre ontarien john
ford lui souhaite aux ontariens de
passer un bon week-end avec leurs amis
et leur famille le premier ministre du
nouveau-brunswick blaine higgs écrit
joyeuse fête du canada à toute la
population du nouveau brunswick nous
sommes tellement chanceux d'être
canadien alors voilà daniel ça se
termine pour cette année voilà un
présentiel
retour à une fête un peu plus normal
c'est toujours plus agréable comme ça
que des trucs virtuel comme on l'a vécue
depuis 2 c'est vrai avec un peu moins de
monde quand même sur les plaines du par
la météo tes potes du côté là mais tu
étais pas là ce que des plaines lebreton
pour s'habituer wallace habituellement
ça pendant quelques années encore
effectivement probablement que dame
nature si dame nature avait été un peu
plus clément tuerie en avoir cruellement
les souni on élit travaux à sur la
colline parlementaire ça devait durer
dix ans bref il doit nos applis a pris
un peu de retard calcul et encore un
autre neuf ou dix ans probablement c'est
toujours compliqué ces travaux-là sur de
vieux édifices peut-être qu'on se
retrouvera la balle
espérons merci daniel les gones étaient
bonnes et et voilà pour cette émission
spéciale ne manquez pas donc ce soir à
20h sur i télé le spectacle la fête du
canada qui mettra notamment en vedette
jean mas carbasse à mian le groupe salle
bach mai merci d'avoir été là je vous
souhaite un très bel été profitez en
bien à bientôt
[Musique]